I think there's a whole bunch of men in
the world who understands my value and
if if men grow up to be like me you're
gonna have a whole bunch of people with
no criminal record dedicated athletes
who protect and provide for the people
close to them are fantastic for the
economy and we're and I'm not I'm
certainly not the worst influence out
here peers you have little Nas twerking
on the devil on music videos which our
children are digesting you have uh
drillar is singing about stabbing people
to death in the middle of a knife crime
epidemic you have rabid uh Psychopaths
on whether the right or the left
announcing violence on the other side
you have all these insanities in the
world and because I sit here and say I
yeah perhaps now you've laid out and it
offended you I understand
okay cool I just read you the things you
read things that you said they could be
offensive and some people are offended
well some people definitely were
offended absolutely that's fine and
honestly I think some of the things you
said were genuinely offensive and
misogynist